when you look at Siegfried and the these
other sort of earlier visions of what
would be you know a newer and and
greater being I I really feel these are
they're very heavily anthropomorphised
as our vogner's gods and the Greek gods
and so forth and when you look for that
the kinds of AR we're gonna be create
creating in the next decades I think
it's important to see how broad the
scope of possible AI Minds is is going
to be so we're we're really at a unique
position in in human history now one
that I think Nietzsche vaguely foresaw
and vogner did not foresee from what I
know of we're at a point where we're
really on the verge of being able to
create minds and and beings that go very
far beyond humanity as far let's say as
we are beyond chimpanzees or cockroaches
or even one celled organisms and that's
that's an amazing thing it's unique in
the history of life on Earth or humanity
right so it's not of course it's not
going to begin that way what we have now
we have what I call narrow AI systems we
have a eyes that can carry out highly
specific tasks and do these things
better than better than humans can so
they can play go better before long
they'll be driving a car better than any
human they can already predict stock
market better analyze DNA better than
people can but they don't understand the
broader context in which they're they're
operating so they're used as tools but
by people rather than being autonomous
intelligent agents right and the next
step which I described in my book they
mentioned the AGI revolution the
artificial general intelligence
revolution the next step is going to be
a eyes that are able to generalize far
beyond their domain of experience which
requires not just solving well-defined
technical problems requires imagination
and and creativity and
the ability to take a bold leap into the
unknown once we have these AGI systems
then of course this will have some minor
social impact like eliminating the need
for all human jobs but medicinally these
AIS will be able to do AI right they'll
be able to design new hardware they'll
be able to write new software they'll be
able to improve their own minds so once
you have an AI which is at the level of
general intelligence of say the people
in this room that AI will then be able
to replicate itself a million times
because you can do that with software it
will be able to improve its own Hardware
introspect into its own mind and
software and improve itself but then
once it's made itself a little smarter
it will be even smarter at making itself
smart and then you will repeat and the
this this is how you will get a mind
that is is tremendously superhuman not
not a Superman as Nietzsche called it by
the super mind a super being and you
have to imagine at a certain point in
this sort of AI will leave
humanity as such far behind just as
we've left fish and and once all
organisms
far behind but the scope of
possibilities is really quite broad and
people tend to anthropomorphize
tremendously and think that you know AI
Minds going beyond humanity they're
either going to be our slaves or they're
going to want to imprison us or oppress
us we tend to envision these AIS as
smell entering into human drama and and
human emotion and human society worse
actually you know if you think about how
we relate to answer squirrels we have no
we have no desire to mess with their
love lives or argue with them over a
leaf or an acorn there's something right
we're we're just we're just occupied
with different with different things so
having said that that I think ultimately
through recursive self-improvement and
eyes are going to become tremendously
more intelligent and capable than human
beings in ways that no human will be
able to understand without following the
AI and giving up their humanity there
also can I ask you a question certainly
why in the world do you find this a try
it sounds completely horrifying to me
that is to say if they will not be
perfected human beings which you're
saying they won't be they will be an
entirely new class of being then we're
talking about something that will affect
the human world in a way that will make
it unrecognizable to us extinct well do
you think that humans are undesirable
because they're not simply upgraded and
improved right no no I don't know I you
know they're in a rat right well a rat
might but you know there is our you
reminded me there's a passage that I
love in an early 17th century Jewish
philosopher who lived in Prague and what
the philosopher says is he says he
begins by saying that the human being is
and it's the standard medieval
definition he says the human being is
the creature who aspires to perfection
that that is the definition of the human
but then he turns the screw in one more
time and he says and in such a creature
whose definition is the aspiration to
perfection perfection itself would have
to be accounted a flaw and a shortcoming
because that is not what we are that is
not what we are I mean you know the
limitations that you or others want to
transcend and go beyond are actually the
conditions of our definition in other
words there are people who want to
become who fantasized about immortality
but if you study human life you realize
that the relationship between human
meaning and temporality and time is so
great that if you erase if you sever
that connection you may get some new
kind of creature but it's not clear that
that that that Redemption will be
meaningful to the creature who's
redeemed I don't understand I don't I
mean it all sounds the fact that we can
do it doesn't mean that we should I mean
this is the case with all I mean there's
a number of issues here so one is
whether this advent of
super intelligences is likely to happen
the other is whether it's desirable in
some general sense the other is why I
personally think it's a good thing and
the first the first one of these is
easiest I think it's gonna happen
because advanced diatom technology has
so much economic and humanitarian value
each step along the way that a eyes that
people build are making money for people
and the delivering good but by curing
curing diseases by eliminating human
drudgery so where it's not like nuclear
weapons that blow people up and don't
have much you said there was I mean
because that ultimately would eliminate
humanity a human being about another I
did not say will eliminate human beings
but by any means and humans have not
eliminated and squirrels or bacteria
either they still exist and each of
these forms of life and intelligence has
its own beauty and and integrity in the
fact that humans are more generally
intelligent than rats or bacteria
doesn't mean they don't have their own
intrinsic aesthetic or moral value you
book you also write getting old and
dying is with capital that was a very
bad thing better frozen there Robin I
love the circus you also write what I
what I expect from new technologies
world peace immortality for those who
hold it everybody liberated from needing
to work for a living I won't do
radically transform humanity for the
better but again that's that's Nestle
yawns this gets back to one of the
vogner psychological defects that
nietzsche pointed out which is the
exultation of of death as something so
amazing and beautiful and of course we
can find beauty in everything I mean you
can you can find beauty in torture or in
the disfigured corpse if you're if
you're a great artist on the other hand
I think on balance we'd be better off if
we didn't have to have to get old and
die and the fact that people have found
a way why is that why do you think that
I mean putting the pain aside it would
be much better if we could sicken and
die without
but why do you think that immortality is
attract in fact there's an opera you
know it how does the metropolis case
remember in which in which it's a
mystery story and the solution to the
mystery is that the heroine of the Opera
in the 1600s drank a potion that gave
her immortal life and she can't stand it
anymore she just can't stand it proving
things about reality by recourse to
fiction is usually before I did well
hold on hold on we'll just describe what
you just described the the entities and
beings that you just described are at
least as fictional as Elena macropolis I
mean that's a you know you're imagining
something
you